to put it politely this is an evolving
situation but the very latest is that
without any objections from the
metropolitan police the publication of
the su-grey report sue grey herself is
now giving very serious thought to
publishing everything in full that she
was going to publish this week before
the announcement of that police inquiry
we were told differently earlier today
downing street said that maybe she'll
only publish the bits that aren't under
investigation by the police those
parties in whitehall that weren't
terribly serious for instance in the
department for education uh but there
was no plan imminently to publish the
rest of it the controversial bit the bit
that's under police um investigation
that has changed we understand at sky
other outlets understand that the
metropolitan police are making clear all
over the place that they're not trying
to block the publication of the sugree
report and so it can now go ahead will
it well that is the decision for sue
grey in consultation with lawyers and
some officials but sue gray will not i
understand be consulting downing street
boris johnson the political advisers
around boris johnson it isn't
essentially a political question she
won't be consulting uh for instance
simon case the cabinet secretary who's
also been left on something of a naughty
step after his attendance at the party
uh as well so this will be for her
cementing her position as one of the
most important people in the country at
this time when could we see it well
honestly i don't know maybe next week
maybe the week after you have to have
that decision in principle taken uh to
publish it in the first place which
hasn't happened yet we're now just
understanding uh that they are mulling
it as an option a pretty serious option
nobody will put odds on it at the moment
but that
seems to be the direction travel that
the government is going on